And welcome everybody to another zoom call to my volume.
Okay, there's a picture of our garden right there, actually along the side of our deck looking down at our raised bed garden.
Reminder to everybody to look at the announcements.
I don't think they were going to do any announcements this week.
But in a reminder to chat in, you can type in the chat any questions you have if you think of them.
We'll get started on the questions that were submitted.
First question.
Can the rife bulb break and the hammer tube break?
Oh, I know some people have other bulbs for their rife as well.
They would probably haven't gotten those from us because we typically recommend only the hammer bulb or the whatever you want to call it but the cylindrical tube.
Can it break? Yes, it can.
So the most common way that the bulb could break is the wire can pull off of it.
So you have a electrical disconnection.
But it can also break by hitting the ends.
The ends get hit and damaged because the wires then connect to the bulb.
But the bulb is filled with gas and then the electricity goes frequencies are going through that gas.
And that's the treatment phase of the bulb.
And it's picked up on the other side and then carried back for the circuit.
So if you hit the ends of it or you drop the bulb and it bangs on the ground on the end, that would be the second most common way it would break because it disconnected from the glass.
That's not repairable.
Typically the first way if it's disconnected at how you plug it into the machine, the little thing that you plug into the machine.
And typically that can be repaired, the which bulb you have.
If you have the ones that we have created, those are repairable.
The true right ones are typically not repairable.
Though I know now that we could probably repair those.
But they're not repairable from true right.
So if that was an issue, we could probably fix that.
But that's very easy visually to see if that is the problem.
It's hard to see if the second most common way, if it's broken off at the bulb itself, it's hard to see if that is the issue.
And it can look completely intact.
Like why is this bulb not working?
It looks perfectly fine.
Now understand if something happens in your bulb is not lighted up on your right machine.
Most of the time it's not your bulb.
You may have blowed a fuse because both common way that one would blow a fuse is that you are accidentally running your your bulb program on the ARR.
You'd be putting it on the AUX setting or on the true right.
You'd have it on the the bath setting.
So if you have the little switch in the front accidentally toggled to the AUX or the true right toggle to the bath and you're trying to run a bulb program, you could blow a fuse.
And then the machine looks like it's running.
The program can even be coated down but there's no light coming out of the bulb.
So that's the most common reason why a bulb doesn't work.
It literally has nothing to do with the bulb. You blowed a fuse on the machine.
Actually, even more common than that is that you actually have it set.
You have that toggle toggled to AUX or toggle to bath and you're running a day program and you're wondering why my light's not working.
And before you blow a fuse, it just won't work.
And if you just toggle it back, the light would come on.
So all these all this information that I'm saying is in your troubleshooting guide that we do ask if something isn't working like your bulb isn't working that you do look at your troubleshooting guide.
Do please look at the frequency healing course.
I have dozens and dozens of videos on the frequency healing course, quite two different troubleshooting as well.
But then the bulb can actually break by the bulb itself breaking.
Now that has never happened in all the years that I've been doing this.
That has never happened with the hammer bulb or the tubular bulb.
It has happened with some of the other bulbs, the spiral bulb.
That's very easily breakable. That's happened multiple times if you drop that, it's going to break.
The true I've used to have a double bubble bulb that was pretty thick glass.
So it was hard to break that but I have had a couple people break that.
And then there's some other bulbs that are breakable that you could break.
So it's obvious if the bulb breaks that way to know that it breaks.
But it's when it's what you can't see that is the issue.
But yes, it is possible to break a bulb.
But make sure you go through the troubleshooting guide because if your bulb is not lighted up most commonly.
It has nothing to do with the bulb. It has something to do with either the setting you are inadvertently running it on.
Remember you have to have it toggled to bulb in order for it to be working.
If you toggle it to back or aux, you could blow a fuse.
And certainly it won't run anything out of the bulb.
So make sure you use your troubleshooting guide.
Make sure you view the videos of the frequency healing course for any other troubleshooting things.
Next question. Can vitamin B17 be toxic?
So B17 is a big deal. Also known as layatril.
I've heard conflicting reports.
I don't think there needs to be any conflicting reports.
Vitamin B17 can be toxic in high doses.
There's no question about that.
Anything could be toxic, right? But I mean, yeah, if we take the whole bottle of something, I guess it could be toxic.
But B17 is different. It could be toxic and relatively lower doses.
If you took the whole bottle of your B17 capsules of apricot power, even the 100 milligram, B17, you would probably be in the hospital getting your stomach pumped.
If you took the 500 milligram tablets, the whole bottle, you would definitely be in the hospital getting your stomach pumped.
Yes, it can be toxic. I think the most that I've ever recommended anybody to take up the B17, 500 milligrams is three per day.
Could it be toxic at that dose? No, it's not going to be toxic at that dose.
Can it stay in your system and build up and be toxic over time? No, no.
It's a water soluble nutrient and it will flush out of your system.
If you took three of them at one time on an empty stomach, and I only weigh 100 pounds, could it be toxic? No.
Could you get a tummy ache from it? I think you get tummy ache from anything.
So it's probably not even the substance that you're going to get tummy ache from. It's probably the capsule.
So in the doses that I've ever recommended, it's not going to be toxic.
I would say that there are conflicted reports out there that basically aren't dissing B17 as a therapy, say that nobody should ever take it because it's a toxic substance.
Let's just nonsense.
It's perfectly safe to use in the right dosage.
And it can be a wonderful cancer killer for people who test well on it.
So we don't have that many people on it, but we've had good success with it.
Is the herb bariga safe to take when one has hormone positive breast cancer?
Yes, I would say bariga is safe for any cancer and it can be beneficial for any cancer.
So bariga is a good supplement we use. We have bariga in our Connor's clinic, but it's an old busher of mix.
We've used it for well over a decade in that, and it has been very good.
So bariga is safe as far as any cancer.
Next question.
I wanted to try nitrous oxide to help with the pain in my thighs that I think is from a lack of oxygen from Martinella is and oh, safe to take with hormone positive breast cancer.
Well, we first need to clarify this.
So nitrous oxide versus nitric oxide.
I think what this person is asking is nitric oxide.
So nitrous oxide is a gas. That's what has been called laughing gas that is still used to the dental industry to take away pain.
Can you get nitrous oxide as a therapy to use for pain in your thighs? I don't believe so.
But it is used to numb the brain, the brain neural center so you don't feel things. That's why it's used to the dental industry.
So when you get laughing gas at the dentist, it is nitrous oxide.
That has negative things to its usage. So I don't think that's what this person is asking, but I want to clarify that.
And I also want to say that getting is a good time to talk about nitrous oxide as a dental as a use in dentistry.
And the negative about nitrous oxide is that it has been shown to completely shut down the methylation pathway for I think up to like two hours.
I think the study show.
So it will literally block everything downstream for methylation for up to two hours. So it can have some huge negative side effects.
So I don't ever recommend using nitrous oxide when you go to the dentist for that reason.
But I don't think this person is talking about nitrous oxide. I think they're talking about nitric oxide.
Very different. So nitric oxide is something to help stimulate blood flow.
What it does is it increases what's called vascular endothelial growth factor.
So nitric oxide is used in a lot of supplements that people would use, whether doing workouts, it can help increase blood flow to the muscles.
It can help with pain, whether there's constriction of the blood flow to an area, nitric oxide will increase blood flow.
So nitric with cardiovascular help, it's used in a lot of supplements for cardiovascular issues because it helps increase cardiovascular flow.
What nitric oxide does is it affects the smooth muscle tissue below the endothelial layer that lines the capillaries.
So it causes vascular dilation because it attaches to certain receptors of those muscles and it causes relaxation.
So therefore it causes vasodilation. So it can decrease blood pressure.
So nitric oxide is great to help with people with high blood pressure.
It's great to help overall healing of the heart because it will stimulate vascular endothelial growth factor which will stimulate more blood vessel production anywhere in the body.
So the heart is definitely needed to have extra what's called an asthmocene vessel. So you get vessels that are growing to add vascularization to the heart.
So if I have blockage in some of my smaller capillaries, capillaries of the heart without an asthmocene vessel that I could end up having a heart attack.
So nitric oxide is a perfect supplement for cardiovascular problems.
However, with anybody with any cancer other than blood cancers like leukemia but any cancer that is what's called a solid tumor cancer which also includes lymphoma.
So breast cancer, any cancer that is not leukemia or multiple myeloma put it that way.
So any cancer other than leukemia and multiple myeloma nitric oxide sets it increases vascular endothelial growth factor.
It can also increase growth of blood vessels into a cancer increasing the ability for cancer to grow faster.
So what is the purpose in both alternative cancer therapy and standards of care cancer therapy is to decrease vascular endothelial growth factor.
We don't want to be doing things that increase vascular endothelial growth factor.
So nitric oxide would be contraindicative in any heart or solid tumors, other than leukemia or multiple myeloma.
So if you have leukemia or multiple myeloma then it really isn't the heart of a taking nitric oxide.
If you have anything other than leukemia or multiple myeloma then you should not be taking nitric oxide.
Now the struggle with that comment is what if a person has a comorbidity of cardiovascular disease that's not uncommon just because you have cancer doesn't mean you don't have cardiovascular disorders as well.
Very common number would cause a death in the United States is cardiovascular disorders.
So how do you balance that? I have very high blood pressure, I have no, I have blocked arteries, I know I have vascular issues and I don't want to die of cancer, but I also don't want to do cardiovascular disease.
Well, if your cancer is in a relative state of remission then I would say that you're probably okay taking nitric oxide.
If you're not in a state of remission at all or you don't know that you are in a state of remission then I would not be taking nitric oxide.
So again, nitric oxide is not considered safe to take for people with solid tumors.
They need any tumors other than leukemia and multiple myeloma because it increases vascular endothelial growth factor and it could increase the vascularization of that tumor and increase the growth of that tumor.
So no, it's not safe to take.
Next question. When talking to you on a recent phone visit you mentioned that you sell a supplement in your store and it's helpful to take after doing scans or testing involving radiation.
Could you please name those supplements?
So we have two homeopaths for radiation.
Whether you're doing radiation as a therapy or you're doing a CT scanner or a PET scan.
So those would be the scans that you're using radiation.
One is called radiallogen by professional health products and the other one is our radiation homeopath.
So if you just call Megan at the store she can help you with that.
Just call our store number. You'll see that on our store website.
You can she can help you with that if you can't find that.
That goes for you can find something any supplement that you're looking for and you can't find it.
You understand, you know, we don't have a whole lot of control over the search ability.
Shopify. Megan and I frequently have words about how we feel about Shopify's searching capability or lack there of gets very frustrated.
The back end as well, back end is even worse.
So if you can't find something just always call the store if you're looking for it.
But radiallogen is the php product.
I think our product is called radiation homeopath.
Now, if a person is doing MRI, that's a different homeopath.
So that's the gadolinium homeopath.
So MRI with contrast that is.
So gadolinium is a heavy metal that is used as a contrast agent for MRIs with contrast.
And many people don't detoxify that very well.
That effect when we do a heavy metal profile on people that have had MRIs,
it's we can see whether they detoxify it or not.
We've had we've done lots and lots of heavy metal panels on people and we get one.
Get them back that they have had a lot of MRIs with contrast and they don't show elevated gadolinium.
That means their detox pathway for gadolinium.
I don't know if it goes on the pun one pathway or some site of compete for 50 pathway.
But that pathway is pretty clean and they're able to flush it under their system.
Other people, they have skyrocket high gadolinium levels.
Beating that they just don't detoxify that well.
And that's where that homeopath comes in play and can help pull that out.
And you want to do some other things to help that pathway as well.
But that homeopath will help.
So the homeopath, there's a homeopath for the radiation.
And that would be if you're doing radiation or you're doing a CT scan or PET scan or a lot of X-rays or something.
And then there's a homeopath for gadolinium if you're doing MRI with contrast.
Next question.
I often wake up at two or three o'clock in the morning.
It takes me almost two hours to get back to sleep.
I was looking at a sleep age for aid from black forest products that contained,
right of a D magnesium on the deodyde,
apaginid and black pepper extract.
I wonder if that's safe for me to try.
It may, but so so the
you're going to look at what could be the problem.
So if a person can't fall asleep,
then that's typically an issue with melatonin.
An issue with clovey their brain down.
Many times, if you're looking at your screen, whether it be your phone or a computer or a television at night,
that's basically, basically,
program in your brain because all screens are vibrate at 60 hertz.
So you're basically up programming to a, you know, your brain to a super high beta wave.
And you have to get down to a theta wave about 11 hertz in order for your brain to calm down enough to fall asleep.
So it's not advisable that you use do a lot of screen time before you go to bed if you're having trouble falling to sleep.
You could also have an issue with melatonin release and you're not releasing melatonin.
It could be a melatonin problem.
There could be other issues too if you can't fall asleep.
But if your thing is, no, I fall asleep just fine.
I just wake up at two or three in the morning and I just can't get back to sleep.
Then that's usually not always, but usually a cortisol issue.
So cortisol is released by your adrenal glands throughout the night in order for you to stay sleeping.
So understand, you know, during the daytime,
you are up walking around moving your eating food and that is helping you when you eat food,
you're breaking it down to glucose and you know, you use the glucose in your muscles to create energy.
But your brain uses glucose as well.
The primary fuel source for your brain is glucose.
In fact, it's said by functional neurologists that your brain needs fuel.
So the fuel is glucose and oxygen to keep your brain alive.
You just need it.
You need glucose and oxygen to keep your brain alive.
So if you're not breathing well, so you could have a sleep apnea issue
where you're not getting proper oxygenation into to help with the brain.
That could be an issue.
And then the other thing is you're not getting enough glucose in the brain to keep the brain alive.
So then you can't fall asleep and you get up and you walk around and when you get up and walk around,
then you will help break down glucose through a process called,
you'll actually create glucose through a process called gluconeogenesis.
And that's how you'll have glucose to the brain.
And then your brain can start functioning and you could go to sleep.
Because literally when a person gets up in the middle of the night and they can't go back to sleep,
many times it's their brain saying, uh-uh, I need fuel.
You need to give me some fuel.
Now the thing is in the middle of the night, you're fasting.
So two o'clock in the morning, you're waking up.
You didn't eat since nine o'clock at night.
So you're already on a five hour fast.
And where is that glucose coming from for the brain?
And it has to come from stores of glucose that is in your liver in the form of glycogen.
So glucose is stored in this long chain of glucose called glycogen and stored in your liver.
And in order for that to break down, it breaks down through cortisol release.
So cortisol is released by adrenal glands.
And then it breaks down glycogen in your liver.
And that's how you have fuel all night long for your brain.
So if you look at a cortisol reading a daily adrenal, what's called it, has been known as an adrenal stress test.
It's measuring cortisol four times during the day.
And in the morning you'll see this spike of cortisol.
Well the spike of cortisol in the morning is coming from a spike that happens at the middle of the night.
You're not getting up to test your cortisol in the middle of the night.
But you could test it in the morning and it's coming down from the highest level of cortisol in the middle of the night.
The purpose of high level of cortisol in the middle of the night, why?
By under stress in the middle of the night, everybody thinks cortisol is just the stress hormone.
Well it's not a stress hormone.
It's released at times of stress.
Why?
It's released at times of stress because at times of stress you need a whole lot of glucose in order to run away from the polar bear.
But you need glucose.
So cortisol's purpose is to break down glycogen stores in the liver so that you can have glycogen.
So you can have glucose to either run away from the polar bear if that stressful event happens at three o'clock during the daytime.
But it also happens at night time every night in order for your brain to stay alive because you're not eating at night.
So you're not eating at night.
You're not walking around at night.
So you're not getting glucose from food and you're not getting glucose from gluconeogenesis.
So you need glucose from glycogen stores in your liver.
Now there's probably way too much information.
Hey I just want to know what I should take a two o'clock in the morning.
Well, a couple of things.
You need to support if you're waking up at two o'clock in the morning I said all that to say that you might have low adrenals.
That's why you would have low cortisol.
So supporting the adrenal glands.
Now ashwagandha in this product actually is an adaptogen that would help support the adrenal glands.
None of this other stuff would help support the adrenal glands.
But ashwagandha would.
I bet you this magnesium is micrograms of magnesium because 1100 milligrams of magnesium is going to give you diarrhea.
So I bet you that's micrograms.
But ashwagandha would support the adrenals.
So in that sense I think this might be a good product.
But better than that, there's some other adaptogens on the market that have other adaptogens other than just ashwagandha.
Like rodeola and ginseng and things like that.
I would say you might get better relief or better results from going on an adaptogen.
If you said I'm really having trouble falling asleep that I would say go on something like insomnia tall which has a bunch of things to help call your brain to help you fall asleep.
The only is one of those things that helps call your brain to help you fall asleep and say with apogen.
Magnesium, depending on the form of it, if it's magnesium, DNA, then it would help call your brain.
But I don't know what form of magnesium it is.
Black pepper just helps you absorb things in the gut.
And I'm not a real big fan of black pepper because black pepper helps you absorb anything that's in the gut.
So if you have ate something with toxins in it or chemicals in it, you're going to absorb it better in the gut.
So I'm not a big fan of black pepper. I wouldn't be a big fan of this product.
I would say take a product that's an adaptogen to help support cortisol levels.
That's how I would do it.
I bet you if we did it in adrenal stress test that you, your adrenals are just a little fatigued.
So then what would you do to help build them up?
You could take an adrenal supplement that has adrenal tissue in it, like a bionics research,
adrenal supplement.
Or I think better would be to take an adaptogen.
So we have adaptogen R3.
That's a product from Premiere Research Lab.
Gosh, we probably have.
We have our own adaptive clear.
We have probably six or seven adaptogens in the store.
I would start with the Premiere Research Lab adaptogen R3.
That's what I would do.
It's called adaptogen R-3.
Take maybe two or three of those throughout the day because you want to try to build your adrenals up throughout the day.
And see if that, give it a week or two before you're going to notice any difference.
That's, I think, what I would do.
Next question.
So back to that question.
The whole thing to be spilling out way too many words is that whatever you have a problem,
like, you know, I wake up at two o'clock in the morning or I can't get to sleep at night or I have headache,
you always want to try to figure out why.
We don't want to go, oh, here's this supplement for waking up at two o'clock in the morning.
Or here's this, like you're just, like we're using, using even natural things as medicine.
We want to figure out why and treat them.
Why and not just throw things at the wall.
So that's why I'm offering my suggestions.
Next question.
Do you think it's important to use organic alcohols when you make your own tinctures?
We do.
I do.
It's just as easy to get it.
And as well, we use it organic vodka.
I can't remember the name on it again, probably does.
Yeah, so yeah, I think it's a good idea, whatever you use anything to use organic because alcohol is made from grains.
And I'm sure it's filled with all sorts of, you know, pesticides and herbicides if we really looked at it.
So I would definitely use it organic.
Is there any harm in taking adding high dose enzyme therapy to my protocol?
I've been reading your information on Dr. Gonzalez.
So Dr. Nicholas Gonzalez was one of my teachers to use a great guy.
I liked him a lot and he was a protege and Dr. William Kelly.
Well, he took a lot of information from Dr. William Kelly that he wrote several books on Dr. William Kelly.
And he believed highly in high dose enzyme therapy.
So he developed a product with allergy research.
That's called pancreas pork.
And it's using pork enzymes, very high dose.
And the theory was that very high dose enzymes take it on an empty stomach or relatively empty stomach.
Some of you absorb them.
Now, typically you take enzymes to help digest your food, but this is taking enzymes in excess that then you'd absorb these enzymes
and these enzymes would work in your body.
They could help clean up, you know, clean up waste in your body.
But the real purpose with somebody with cancer would be to help break down the waste layer that's around the cancer.
So then any other therapy can attack the cancer.
So is there any danger in taking using high dose enzyme therapy for someone?
No, I don't think in general.
No, I don't think there is a danger for anybody using high dose enzyme therapy.
Is there downsides to high dose enzyme therapy?
Well, just about a pill that you have to swallow depending on when high dose you're going.
Dr. Gonzalez used to have people take upwards of 75 in the morning and 75 in the evening.
Now, you don't have to go that high of a dose to still get some benefits of relative high dose therapy.
But I don't see any negatives to doing any high dose enzyme therapy.
You could make a giant argument.
I think I have a video out there somewhere I talked about this a couple years ago.
Some research that came out that studied the different CT scans and MRIs of the general populace that they came to a working.
Prognosis that people have it in large to pancreas.
It was a study on why is pancreatic cancer rates going up.
And they said that study showed that there that people in general have a much larger pancreas than previous generations.
The theory was that we're eating more chemicals in our foods that are denatured enzymes in the gut.
And therefore our pancreas is forced to enlarge to make more enzymes.
And there were having a relative decrease in enzyme utility and functionality.
And therefore that's partly of what it can be causing disease and partly what can be leading to inflammation in the pancreas and therefore dysfunction and eventually cancer.
So I don't know how much that theory has been proven but it does make sense from a working hypothesis that we do put a lot of stress on our pancreas that I have thought.
Often about why functional medicine doctors from many years ago have recommended using pancreatic enzymes and have had success with not with cancer patients which is the general populace.
It's because our pancreas is already straight and most people haven't pancreatic insufficiency.
So that's the inability of the pancreas to keep up with the production of enzymes needed to help clean out the gut to digest food partially because our food is so adulterated.
So you can't argue with that whole theory because it's been proven to be true from a functional standpoint.
So adding more enzymes to your protocol could never be harmful per se.
Okay, questions from the chat. I've heard Ashwagandha is poorly absorbed. I've been putting Ash powder in Ashwagandha powder in my smoothie.
Do I need to add something to help it absorb?
I don't know what else you would add to help Ashwagandha be absorbed.
I'm sorry, I don't have an answer for you there.
What would you recommend for a stomach virus with nausea, headache, many loose stools, very weak, very low energy?
Well, you know, how would you know what's a virus?
Well, if you did a CBC with a differential, if you're thinking you have a virus or some sort of infection, things that would give you clues.
You'd have an elevated white blood cell cone, which may still be within normal lab range, but is outside of functional range.
Remember, that's probably the biggest discrepancy of any blood value is the white blood cell cone.
Lab range and white blood cell cone can be 4.0 to, you know, upward to 12. They still consider normal.
Whereas a functional white blood cell cone is maybe 4.5 to upwards to maximum of seven, anything over that would be considered.
You probably have an infection. So let's say you have a 8.5 white blood cell cone.
Then you look at the differential. If neutrophils are elevated over lipocytes, then you most likely have a bacterial infection.
If lipocytes are elevated over neutrophils, then you most likely have a virus.
So that's how you do to a cursory clue of do I have a virus or do I have a bacterial infection?
Because you would trade it a little differently. Now, either one you would use, you know, some, you know, this pretty much a similar nutraceuticals.
Anything that's going to be an immune system is immune booster is going to help.
But if it's bacterial infection, you know, you might hit it a little bit harder on garlic and oregano.
And then you depended on what you think what you think it could be like H. Pylora. You might hit it with burberry and things like that as well.
Definitely you want to calm down the dot. And if your stools are loose, decrease magnesium, decrease something that would make it looser.
And add some fiber to see if that can help bite things up.
So those are things that you want to think of get a proper diagnosis, whether it's a bacterial infection or it's a virus.
And then either way from a nutraceutical standpoint, you're going to use immune stimulants to help kill it.
PubMed is adapted in R3 is now called fatigue support.
The products we're still getting in from them is adapted to the R3. But thank you for that.
We'll have to look and see if they're if they change their name. We'll probably get the next labels in pretty soon.
Any other questions? If you're new, you could just chat your questions in.
We have some new people on here. And remember on the member site, you can always type in your questions and hit submit.
And those will be part of the picture here.
All right, well, thank you everybody for being on reminder to everybody to be prayed for each other.
It's very helpful. We are thinking about other people and be praying for each other.
I think that's very powerful. No, that we're always praying for you. And we cherish your prayers for us.
We'll see you guys all next week. All right. Bye.